それから仏教の話 仏教における地獄の話
多宗教の思考 民間的信仰
神話なども一般仏教の考え方に入り混じっている
で 仏教的な地獄の話になってくると
ちょっとややこしいことがありまして
いろいろ他の宗教の思考
それから民間信仰とかも入り混じってるんですよ
で もう学者が間違っている
お釈迦様の教えっていうのは
何でも他人からパクったというふうなね
日本の偉大なる中村先生からね
みんなそう思ってますけど
まあこれはとんでもない学問的な誤りであって
お釈迦様はすべて自分で発見して語ったもので
誰からもパクったものじゃないんですよ
地獄の話も自分で発見して語ってますけど
人間に喋る場合は 人間信じている民間信仰とかね
神話とかは使いますね
そこで地獄の話っていうのは
ブッダ以前からずっと世界でありましたから
これなんとなく入り混じってしまうんですね
だからずっとお釈迦様だけ話しているわけじゃないんだから
みんなお釈迦様から話を聞いてもう言ってるんだからね
もうなかなか入り混じったりするんで
そこはちょっと避けられないんですね
しかし 無常の話とかね
苦の話とかね 四聖諦の話
八正道の話になってくると
もう入り混じることはできません
たとえ我々はブッダの話を伝えたっても
自分の信仰やらね 民間の神話とかは変えれません
で 大変 まあそういうわけで
この教法に教評に結構困っているんです
だって地獄の話は大教法だから
いろんな信仰が入り混じって困ってるんです
地獄の話は一般的に人気があるんですよ
結構人気があるんです
仏教以前からも 民間的にも信じていたというのは疑問ですけど
多宗教でもよく語られた話ですからね
だから人気あるんですよ
だから仏教も地獄の話になってくると
もう人気あるもんだから
どうも困ったことになる
一般の方々は論理的な説明より神話的な物語
物語が好きです 人間っていうのは
論理の話より物語で言った方がもう聞きやすくて好きでしょうに
仏教徒の間でも 世間一般的に言われている地獄に関わる話が入り込んでしまった
そういうわけで だからバラモン教でいろんな宗教である
あの地獄の話なんかはもう物語ですからね
神話だから 多宗教の場合は経験ではありませんだから
まあすごい軽々く入ってしまうんですね
時々我々は仏教の話だと思って
全く仏教と関係ない話をしているんです
これは地獄の場合はいつでもそうなっちゃうんですよ
はい どこまで仏教か どこまで民間信仰かわからなくなってる今は
で 私はこの地獄に対して結構調べた
結構と言っちゃっても
ちょこちょこと調べたんですけども
ものすごい大量なんですね
データは それでもうテキスト手に今入らないんですけども
覚えているところはもう時々どんなテキストにどうあったかとか覚えてないほどものすごいたくさんあるんです
地獄の話 あるわあるわあるわ
もうキリがなくある それで一般的に私たちに子供の時からいろんな大人に教えてくれた物語
エピソードやらまだいろいろあるんですね
その中でどこまで仏教か
どこまで違うかってわからなくなっているぐらい
地獄の恐ろしさ 餓鬼道のみじめさなどを自由自在に表現したので
文学的な話にもなっている
そこで人間っていうのは
地獄は恐ろしいんだそうよと
餓鬼道っていうのはものすごい惨めだよと
というと 仏教の人々もものすごいもう調子に乗って説明するんですよ
だから説明すると とにかくイメージというか
イメージネーションを働かせ
働かせて語る 自分の国でも結構そういう作品はあるんですね
地獄の恐ろしさ語っていて
餓鬼道の惨めさを語っている作品なんかはね
だからお釈迦様とは関係ないんですね
結局は お釈迦様の教えだけにとどまる気持ちはない
なさそうです だからお釈迦様がおっしゃっているところだけちゃんと参考して言えばいいんだけど
それもなかなか怖い話ですけど
そうとどまらないんですね
罪を犯せないようにような話ですので
仏教側から異議ありとも言わないのです
だから仏教の学者とかね
もう仏教をわかっている人々は
こんなのは違うんじゃないかということはあまり言わない
なぜかというと この地獄の話はものすごい面白おかしくして喋る人々は
目的は悪くないんですよ
人を脅すつもりはないんです
ただ とにかく悪いことはやめましょうと
例えば 花 1本でも盗んだら
なんとか地獄のうちとすごい怖い地獄を描いてあって
あるお寺で こんなそんなもんだったら
やっぱりもうそんなことはないと思いますけど
やっぱりそれ見る子供たちやら
もう普通のおじさんおばさんたちやら
やっぱり花 1本でも糸1本でも
他人のものを盗んではあかんやというふうに気持ちにはなりますから
仏教は放っておいているんです
仏教的でない話であろうとも
はい それからまた仏教的にもっとお釈迦様に近くなって
話に話を進んでいきます
ポイント第１ 地獄があるのかっていうこと
地獄というところが本当にあり得る
ありますかと お釈迦様の教えから見るとき
どうなるのでしょうか？と
まず それを解決しなきゃいけないんですよ
だから これから皆様 一般的に民間的に信じている世界とは微妙に変わってきますよ
そこら辺覚悟しておかないと
はい 次に行きます また地獄の色になりました
生きている上での苦と楽の問題
まずこれを理解するために
この苦と楽の問題ということを考えてみます
人間の次元は苦と楽の割合は点にしてみましょう
まず我々は人間の世界中心に考えます
で 人間には世界は楽ですかと
苦ですかというと まあ五分五分やと
楽しみもあって苦しみもあるんだと
いうと点にしておくんで
これはもう仮の話で 仮定的な話で
それわかるでしょ 我々は楽しいんだけど
純粋に楽しいわけでもないんですね
楽しみを得るために苦労もしなくちゃいけない
はい 次 それより苦の割合は多い方がアパーエといいます
それで人間は苦も楽も五分五分
ある生命の場合は 苦は大きくて
楽は少ない 苦しみの方が生きる苦しみの方が多いんです
その次元に仏教はアパーエという一言葉使ってます
アパーエドゥッガティ
ヴィニパータ ニレーという語も
もうちょっと もあります
もうちょっと抜けてます
で パーリ語でだいたいこの同義語をたくさん使いますから
アパーエドゥッガティ
ヴィニパータ ニレーという単語もあります
そこであっていうのは収入
得 利益なんですよ アッパーっていうのは逆
まあは逆なんですね だから収入には収入は逆になるって意味なんです
利益が逆になるって意味でマイナスですね
したがって アッパーとは赤字の生き方ですよ
人間より不幸な生命なんです
もうすごい論理的にお釈迦様が単語使ってます
脅しじゃないんですよ
もう人生は得しなくちゃいけないんですよ
黒字出して生きてなくちゃいけないんですけど
まあ赤字ばっかしの人生だったら
ちょっとアッパーなんですね
これ 人生だけじゃないんです
これは 全ての生命 生命の次元たくさんありますからね
生命の次元で人間は点にしてみると
苦も楽も五分五分で苦が多い生命もいるんです
楽が少ない生命もいるんです
その生命は全部アッパーと言うんです
彼らが その生命がいくら頑張っても頑張っても
楽はほんの稀で少少で苦は大きいんです
あのもう例えばこの地獄餓鬼道の掛け軸とか
ごご覧になったことあるでしょ？あれがこういう餓鬼がいるんですよ
でお腹がものすごい大きい
まあ牛 牛肉でいえば牛ももうもう 5等分食べたっても
もうまだ入るような まだお腹が空いているぐらいのお腹がすごい大きい
お腹が大きい巨大な体だから
大量に食べなくちゃいけない
しかし この餓鬼の首は針ぐらい小さいんです
細い 小さな細い管なんですね
首は 首だけ口も大きいんです
お腹に合わせて頭も大きいんです
それでも立てないんだから
どうせもう転がっています
そうすると考えてください
どれぐらい食欲あるのかと
そうすると食べ物があると
どれぐらい食べたいという気持ちが生まれてくるのかと
それで食べられるのかと
食べられないでしょうに
あのハエのハエも吸って食べてるでしょうに
ハエのあの管も結構太いんですよ
針よりは太いんです ハエは簡単にお腹いっぱい食べられますけど
そうすると この餓鬼が食べ物が大量にあると
もう食べようと思っても
ものすごい大量にものを一食で食べなくちゃあかんでしょうに
でも一生あれ 吸って食べても食べても入りませんね
だから食べ物にありつけたというかすかな楽しみがあるんだけど
食べられないという苦しみっていうのはすっごい大きいんですね
だから微妙に 1 ぐらい楽しみがあると
もうもう 1兆ぐらいの苦しみがあるという割り当て
それは表現するために
そういうでっかいお腹の餓鬼が餓鬼をイメージして
細い首があって すごい大きい頭をイメージしています
だからそれはアッパーなんですね
人間の場合はもう簡単に食べられますね
もう食べ物あればもうもう 10 分でも食べられますよ
お腹いっぱい どうせみんな飲み込むだけだからね
今はもう噛んで食べるわけでもないし
だからみんなすごいもう食べ物に執着
依存してるでしょ だって味わったことはないんだから
ヘビみたいに何度も飲み込む
これやめた方がいいと思いますけど
なんか餓鬼道と同じく
別に餓鬼道じゃないんだからね
ゆっくり食べても誰も盗みはしません
ゆっくり噛んで味わって食べると
人間としての幸福が増えるんですよ
それは余計な話でね 一応そういうふうなことで仏教の地獄の話が成り立つんです
一応論理的でしょ？人間の空と楽の問題だよ
人間ではなくて 生命の空と楽の問題だよと
はい 人間の生き方は苦楽ゼロですかと
これはちょっと疑問なんですよ
ただ 仮にゼロにしたんです
お釈迦様は仏教でもそうやって仮にゼロにするんだけど
本当は人間の世界も苦の方が多いんです
でも我々は楽に酔ってますから
楽しみに酔ってますから引き算しません
例えば赤ちゃんが生まれてくると
もう楽しみに酔っちゃいますね
赤ちゃん育てる苦しみはもうもうもう計算に入れません
引き算にしないんですね
それ入れて引き算してみると赤字なんですけど
標準値はに近いとするしかないんです
ですから まあ人間の最高な立派な幸福で
もう満たしていると 我々から見れば
あの人ならもう健康で
もうもう美しくて豊かで
金もあって 収入もあって
大金持ちで何の問題もないんだぞという人が標準値にすると近いと言ってもいいんですね
天界の苦はいろいろ制限があることのみほとんど楽です
天界の苦ですよ 天界に生まれたら苦しみがあるんですよ
神になっても で 他宗教で言うのは天界は極端な話ってことは仏教は言わない
天界に生まれても苦しみはあるんです
でもそれ大した苦しみじゃないんです
仕事をする苦しみもないし
もう料理する苦しみとかそんなのはないんですよ
この制限があるということだけなんですね
ほとんど楽しみ 天界は
はい 次 梵天は楽しみのみ
制限はないんです 梵天に生まれたら
それは瞑想しなきゃいけないんです
苦といえば寿命があることです
瞑想して梵天に生まれたら
もう何光年もいますけど
何も苦はないんです 楽だけ
苦がそれでもあるといえば
寿命があるんですね まあ光年というのは
この宇宙の時間時間で
宇宙一つ現れて消える時間は一光年になるんです
だからそれでまあ十光年
四十光年 八十光年とか生きてるんですよ
これで百光年生きていたっても
寿命は寿命です それ終わったらもう亡くならなくちゃいけないんです
まあそこだけですね 苦として残っているのは
はい 人間以下の次元は苦はほとんどで
楽は稀です それで人間はゼロに近いにしたでしょ
人間以下になってくると
次元的に苦だばっかしなんですよ
楽しみは稀なんです はい
アパーエは三つです そこで人間以下はアパーエと言うんですよ
人間はには何も言わないで
人間上はもう天と言うんですね
時々人間の世界も もう神々の世界も一つにまとめてスガティという場合もあります
スガティドゥッガティっていうのはアパーエ地獄のことで
アパーエのことで スガティっていうのはもっと良い生まれということで
まあ良い生まれという単語を使っちゃうと
人間も神々も同じカテゴリーに入るんです
そこで神々はこういうことを言うんだそうです
神々の間で長い間一緒に楽しんで
でもう寿命になっているでしょ
神々は寿命になっているとよくわかるんですよ
服がちょこっと汚れるんだそうです
微妙に ちょっと微妙に疲れが見えます
微妙なんです それで花とかいろいろアクセサリーつけてますけど
それもちょっとしぼんでいったりする
そうなると 髪の服装やらね
顔色が微妙に疲れが見えると
他の神々がもうあ この人は終わりと仲間が集まるんですよ
集めてこう言うんだそうです
で まあもう敬語なんですけど
日本語ではね もう敬語の単語はないんだからね
君でいいんですけどね
まあまあ 英語だったらそれという言葉あるでしょうしね
まあ君 まあここからね
亡くなって天界に生まれてちょうだいと
言うと この天界は何でしょうかというと
だって人間の世界でしょうにと
だから神々から見れば
人間の世界は羨ましがる天界なんですよ
寿命は短いんですけど
その理由は 人間に生まれたら善行為できるんですよ
良いことをできるんです
徳を積めるんです 瞑想もできるし
もう大胆に徳を積むことはできるので
天界に生まれたらできません
だから自分たちが何かやられたという感じで
えらいところに生まれてすごい楽しくはいるんですけど
自分の業が減るんであって
新しい善行為して増やすことは難しい
まあ神々もお釈迦様のところに説法を聞きに来たんですけど
そんな長い時間延々と説法したりすることできないんですよ
そちら命に関わっているんだからね
人間と違うんですよ 人間はまあ日食ぐらい飛ばしちゃったっても死にませんでしょうし
だから大変な制限入ってますよ
幸福なところなんですけど
だから神々がまあ死にかけてる神神々のところに行ってアドバイスするんだそうです
これから全てに生まれ変わってくださいと
良いところに生まれてくださいと言って
人間の世界に放り出そうとするんだそうです
それで来てもいいんだけど
それから何やってるのかと
人間に生まれて まあこれはまた分かったもんじゃないんですけどね
もう徳を積むどころか
もうもう住んでる徳ももう粉々に壊せるようなことばっかりやってますけど
それからこの人間以下のアパーエですね
今日のお話は人間以下のアパーエは３つですよ
一般的に４つだと言っていますが
経典では３つです  1ニレイ地獄ということ
地獄にティラッチャーナのように畜生
サンペッティリセ餓鬼道
阿修羅は阿修羅ですね
は後から付いたので これはもしかすると仏教に後から付いた話だと思います
経典では阿修羅という地獄はないんです
日本仏教では 順番なんでしょうかね
日本の場合は  地獄餓鬼畜生修羅人天の順番でございます
地獄餓鬼  地獄一番下が地獄から
はい 地獄餓鬼  畜生 畜生
修羅  人  はいはい  OK です
はいはい だからこの順番知りたかったんです
その順番も正しいんですよ
苦しい順番で苦しみは減る順番ですから
一番苦しいのは地獄ですね
次に来るべきのは餓鬼道なんですよ
で  3番目は畜生なんですね
次に阿修羅なんですね
私は阿修羅は 4番やと言いたいだけなんです
これは後からついたんだからなんです
お釈迦様のこれを参考している経典では
この順番なんです これはかなり古い経典で
マッジムニ会の 1番目の 12番目の経典ですね
お釈迦様の経典を見ると
お釈迦様は随分このもう気楽というかね
あんまり厳密に地獄のことを説明しようとしていないんです
仏教は その時 その時 なんとかおっしゃるだけで
この関係あるところだけ明確に分析しようとはしないんです
で なぜかというと この具体的に理解できないものは
ちょっともう抑えるんです
はい それでこのいろんなところを参考にしてみたんですけど
あるジャータカ物語で
この物語ではなくて このジャータカの古い一番古い経典のところで
ある人が人は悪いことをして地獄に落ちるんだという話が聞いているんですけど
地獄ってどういうものか質問するんですよ
そうすると 答える方は地獄の話ではなくて
善行為とか天の話をして
最後に地獄はこれくらいあるんだよと言って
ちゃちゃっと終わっちゃうんですね
そちらに説明に行かない
そうすると ジャータカの物語のところを読んでみると
やっぱり人間には地獄の話を言うと
みんな怯えて怖くなって
大変なことになるかもしれませんよと
ですから 地獄の恐ろしさ言う前に
天国の楽しみやら幸福を教えてあげた方が安全だということで
人間の心を大事にするんですよ
脅したりはしないこと
すごく気をつけるんで
ショックを受けたら困ると
本当に地獄の話を聞きちゃうと
もういてもたってもいられないぐらいショックなんです
すごい怖いんです それで阿修羅っていうのは後からついた話ですから
そちらをちょっと説明します
阿修羅はなんなのかと
だから この仏教の地獄の話に
このなんかどこか割り込んじゃうんですよ
お釈迦様は阿修羅入れてない
地獄として 修羅は天神々で
阿は非ない否という意味なんですね
阿修羅っていうのは神でないというよね
だからもう漢字はないんですけど
性格は反対の同じ次元の生命体ではないでしょうかと
だから神と同じ次元なんですけど
性格は反対 だから神と神でないものというふうにしているんですよ
人間と人間でないものやというような感じで
まあわかりやすく言えば
この野党と与党みたいなもん
みんな議員ですよ みんな議員だけど
どこかで違うんですね
野党と与党は 互いにいつでもやり合ってるんです
喧嘩するんです もう滅多なことにももう同意しない
修羅と阿修羅の戦いはもともとバラモン系の神話です
このバラモン系の神話物語の本がありまして
そちらにはいっぱい物語が書くんですよ
全部もう作り話ですよ
神話なので 仏教でも教訓のためにその概念を使用しています
お釈迦様の経典の中にも
阿修羅の話 修羅の話あるんですよ
エピソードとして そのエピソードがあって
何か仏教の教訓を言うんですよ
一つは このある日 帝釈天は修羅で
神で阿修羅のと戦ったんだと
戦ったら神が負けちゃったんだと
で 負けたら逮捕されちゃうんですよ
捕虜になるんです 阿修羅の
そこで負けたんだから
帝釈天は自分のグループを持ってさっと逃げた
ものすごい勢いで捕虜になっちゃいますからね
逃げる途中でなんかどこかのこれもガルダなんですけど
ガルダっていうのはあれも神話的な鳥なんですけど
もう巣を作って卵を雛を守っているんですね
それでこの神々が軍隊でしょうに
ものすごい勢いで逃げる時は
あの巣なんか壊れちゃって
雛たちがキャーキャーと泣き出しちゃった
そしたら大将ってのは命拾いして逃げてるのに
あ あれ何の音かと あ とんでもないことをしたんだと
それ鳥たちに迷惑をかけてはいけないんだと行って
カチンと軍隊をストップさせちゃったんですね
させちゃって戻そう 戻りましょうと
戻って自分たちに壊れた巣とか何とかと
また整理します 整理しましょうと処理しましょうということで言って
落ちた雛をまた戻してあげたりとか
そういうことをしようと思って
いきなり逃げた軍隊がカチンと逆に回ったんです
もう神だからね すぐできます
人間だったら結構時間かかりますけどね
そうすると追っかけてきた阿修羅の神々は
なんだこれと信じられなくなっちゃって
びっくりしちゃって もしかするとこれがやばいと
逃げてる途中はいきなり逆に来るということは
で 我々逃げましょうと
阿修羅たちが逃げちゃったんだ
自分の世界に それで結局はやがて結局は神々が勝ったことになったんだと
で その時でも それ自分の命に危険があっても
大作展はいい神だよと
他人に迷惑をかけませんよという苦労で終わっちゃうんです
だから仏教は このバラモン教にある物語は
そういうふうに使うんです
はい 阿修羅とは何者ということでね
天界の存在を認めているから
性格違いの同じ次元の生命も認めることになる
キャラクターとして阿修羅が出てくる場面は経典にあります
しかし 地獄の主としてではありません
神々と対照すると行儀が悪いという扱いですね
阿修羅というのはそんなもんなんです
はい 次に行きましょうか
それで地獄は成り立つのかという
仏教では論理的にアパーヤが成り立つのです
論理的にはアパーヤが成り立つんですよ
もし神様が地獄を創造して
したならばかな まず慈悲深いその方をそちらに行かせるべきと
だからこの神様が地獄を創造したというとおかしいんですね
神様が慈悲深いでしょうに
世界創造すると いっぺんにもう設計図に地獄も作っておくということはおかしいでしょう
だからいい設計図というか
番線というかね もう完全たる慈悲ということはないんですよ
だから神様の 特にイスラム教のテキストなんか
アッラーの場合はモストコンパッションネイトという言葉を必ず使いますよ
最高な慈悲あるという
慈悲一かけらもないんじゃないかなとと思いますけどね
だからもう意味がないんですね
そんなこと だったらあなたは先に行けと言いたいんですよ
仏教は因縁論を語る 一切は因縁により生じて滅する
仏教というのは因縁論ですよ
人が何か作るんじゃなくて
生命が何か作るんじゃなくて
原因によって現れるんですよ
原因そろったらそちらにその新しい現象がある
それだけの話 物事に心は優先です
ダンマパダにもあるように
このいろんな物質の中でも
心っていうのはすごい強力で優先で偉大なるものなんですね
だから 我々はものとものを混ぜたら新しいものが現れるでしょ
で そんな感じで もう因縁で新しいものが成り立つ
心は一つのエネルギーだから
心によっても新しいものを成り立たせる話で
はい 次に行きます 心の因果法則によるものです
輪廻転生は心のポテンシャル
業による起こるものです
業によって起こるものですね
だから生きているということは
心が回転しているんだということなんです
心が回転やめたら もうその人が死ぬんですね
死んでも心は物質と関係ないものだから
心の回転はやめません
我々の場合は 物質によっても心は回転変えますけど
面白いものを見ると面白くなっちゃうとかね
美味しいご飯を見ると食べたくなるとかね
心が変わりますけど そんなものなくても心が変わることはストップしないんです
すっと変わっていくんです
だから死んじゃっても
心というやつはもうすっと変わっていくんですね
だからこれを輪廻と言うんですね
そこで心にも変わるためにはエネルギーが必要ですよ
ポテンシャルが必要です
それ仏教で業と言うんです
では 汚れた心の行為によってどこに生まれるのでしょうかと
もし心のポテンシャルが汚れたならば
嫉妬 憎しみ 怒り 悲しみ
そういう感情で心が回転して死んじゃったら
どこへ生まれるんで 天界？もうどうせ天界ではないでしょうね
その場合は 汚れた心の行為の結果として
本来より幸福が少ない不幸な次元に再生する
すごい単純な論理なんです
因果法則が難しいんだけど
論理的にはすごい論理で理性的で単純なんですね
今も自分の心は回転している
物質は回転させているわけじゃないんです
物質によっても回転は変わりますが
物質的な影響なくても心は勝手に回転する
回転するためにはやっぱり感情みたいな衝動が必要なんです
それが怒り 憎しみとか嫉妬とかね
落ち込みとか悔しさとか
物惜しみとか そういう感情でいて
またその時死んじゃうと
よく成仏できましたと言えるもんじゃないでしょうに
これ因果法則と違いますからね
だから人間より不幸なところに生まれ変わっちゃうんですよ
それがアパーヤという世界なんです
だから他宗教でいう地獄という随分形が違うんですね
まあもうついでに言いますけど
もう人間っていうのは危ないんですよ
年取って病気になって死にかけてくると
心を清らかにするところじゃなくて
えらいわがままで怒りっぱなしで
もうすごい気持ち悪い性格になるでしょ
ものすごい頑固になっちゃうし
人の話は聞かないわ ある人がもう死にかけているところの私は行きましたけど
でも花も咲いていてね
まあ私はもう来年の花は見られませんとかね
美味しいものはもう全く食べられないんだと
お腹に入りませんと だからちょことなめてみるんだと
その時でも気分がいいんだと
そう言われて まあこの人はもう明らかに死んじゃうと
行くところはもう私にももう見え見え
これまあ とにかく私は知ってる人で
でお見舞いに行ったんですけど
あ これはもうとにかく私のことを知ったんだから
この人は地獄には行けませんと言って
みんなちょこっとあちこちもう一緒に行った人たちと行く間を見て離れていったんです
何やそれと あんたごまかしやってるんだよね
と言ったら 心はやっぱり破れちゃったんですよ
やっぱりそうだと すごいごまかしやっていたんだと言って
ものすごく泣き出しちゃって
で もう欲を捨てる と こういう瞬間にもう 2 3 分で持っていったんです
ちょっともう泣く時間にちょこっとかかったんですけど
その人はね それからすごい穏やかな心
顔になって それからしっかりしたんです
俺もしっかりしていたつもりでしたけどね
で やっぱり人間っていうのは弱いんですよ
危ないし 死にかけてくるとかなり怯えやら恐怖感やらね
例えば若いうちにがんになったと言われると
ものすごい悔しくなっちゃうんですね
なんで私はこうなったんでしょうかとか
こんなもんで死んじゃうともう
因果法則っていうのはもうどうにもならんもんでしょ
悔しい 醜い心で死んだんだから
あの人は天界に生まれ変わりました
成仏できたと言っちゃうと話にならんだからね
だからそこら辺は気をつけてください
人間の弱みっていうのは
常に明るくて すごいいつでも優しい心でいなくちゃいけない
何か不幸に出会っても
なんだこんなもんがっていう
気にするもんかという感じでいなくちゃいけないんですよ
はい 次に行きます だから結論は地獄は成り立つんです
地獄と言っちゃうとちょっとおかしいんですけど
阿婆は成り立つんです
不幸なところに地獄ですね
生まれてもそれは業というエネルギーの結果なので
決勝後の力が尽きたところで地獄の寿命が終わるのです
だから永遠じゃないんです
すごい論理的な話で脅しじゃないんです
地獄に落ちたのは心のエネルギーでしょうに
業でしょうに だからそちらでそのエネルギーで回転してるでしょうに
エネルギーが尽きちゃうと
そこでまた別なところに回転しなくちゃいけない
死ななくちゃいけない
たとえ地獄に落ちても寿命があるんです
仏教では永遠不滅の概念は無知な人間の妄想以外何でもありません
仏教ではね あんなのはもう成り立たない話ですということで
地獄も天界も自分の設計によって行けるところなのです
計画によって 我々は計画立てれば
どこを行こうかな 地獄に行こうかな
天国に行こうかなとかね
計画立てればいいんです
で どこに行ったっても
そのエネルギーが消えちゃったら
また別なところに行かなくちゃいけない
はい 次 で また成り立つのかというね
人間の次元さえも多様多彩なのです
まあ人間0点やといっても効力はね
でも多様多彩でしょう
いろんな人間いるんだから
美しい人もいて まあ美しいとお世辞で言わなくちゃいけない人もいるし
まあ幸福な人もいるし
あんたも頑張れば幸福になるんでしょうという言える言うべき人もいるし
いろいろでしょうに はい
同じくアパーエの次元も多様多彩なのです
だから他の宗教とバラモン教
ヒンドゥー教の影響で単純に理解しようとしない方がいいんですよ
人間の社会さえも理解できないのに
これほど人間様々にいるんだから
ものすごい様々でしょうね
例えば日本人みんな同じ性格と思っても
ものすごい勘違いでしょうね
一人一人日本人が違うでしょうに
まあ似ているところはいくらかあるんですけど
それで日本人と韓国人に比べてみたら
同じ民族なのに随分違うでしょうね
中国人と見てみると まだ随分違うでしょうね
全くもう別世界の人間のように感じる時もあるでしょうに
だから人間の世界さえも多様多彩
これは心の問題で だったらアパーエ
3つのアパーエもそうわかるもんじゃないんで
多様多彩 はい 畜生の次元を見るとわかるのです
畜生っていうのは我々に見えるアパーエですよ
動物の世界 どうですかね
動物の世界は では 虫何種類いるんですかね
足のないこのヘビやらミミズやらね
どれぐらいいるんでしょうかね
ただ アリにアリってしたっても
アリの尻はどうですかね？蜘蛛の尻はどうですかね
アリの中にいますよ このあの何アリと言うんですかね
ファイアーアンツというね
人間捕まってもすぐ食べちゃう
アリですけど もしもアフリカとかにいるんですけど
で そこら辺歩いていて
間違ってでもそのアリの流れ １
匹にでも噛まれちゃうと
アリがホルモン出すんだから
さーっとそのアリたちが来るんです
もう終わり 骨だけしか残らない
全部食べる 逃げられないんですよ
結局は そういうアリもいる
それから葉っぱ持っていってキノコ栽培するアリもいる
ちゃんと農業をやって生活させている
すごい行儀がいいんですよ
いろいろ葉っぱをもう噛んで
小さな葉っぱを食ってみんな運んで
自分の巣の中に置いておくんです
そこで葉っぱで巣の中で栄養をとって
このキノコが 栽培する
これを食べる生活する
いろいろ だからわからないんですよ
いまだにわからないね
動物たち 生命はいっぱいいるでしょうに
だからアパエの世界っていうのはそういうことで
単純に理解してやろうと思っても
例えば我々動物園 すごい苦しんでますよ
楽しみはないんです 人間勝手に思っちゃいますよ
ああ 楽しいなとかね 空を飛ぶ飛んで鳥たちなんか楽しいか
全然楽しくないんですよ
すごい苦しい 我々に飼われている犬の動物たちもものすごい苦しんでるんです
全然楽しくないんです
犬と猫っていうのはもう永遠の奴隷でしょうね
生まれつき奴隷に決まっている
これだけでも不幸でしょ
ヘビは生まれつき奴隷じゃないでしょうね
人間に飼われるために生まれたわけじゃないでしょうに
我々勝手に捕まって飼うだけで
犬猫はそうじゃないでしょ
馬とか牛とかね 人間飼ってる場合は
鶏とかね ちゃんと薬でもあげてるんだから
鶏幸福やと思ってますかね
鶏の前にコンベアベルトで餌が来るんですけど
食べてそのままいればいいんです
あれって幸福だと思うんですかね
とにかく処刑に決めてるような感じでしょうね
すごい苦しんでますよ
はい 人間に大統領 総理大臣などがいるように
アパエの世界にも管理者がいる可能性は否定できません
いろいろ管理者がいる可能性はあります
例えば猿にはボスがいるでしょ
猿の群れに ゾウアザラシの群れでも１匹はもう一頭が偉いボスで
犬も野生でいると群れが作ってボスがいるんですよ
そちらもその人が管理するんです
で ミツバチにすれば女王蜂いるでしょ
アリにもいるし 白アリにもいるし
まあそういう集合的なコロニー作ってる虫はいつでも王様
女王様がいるんですね
動物の世界ではまあ一応ライオンとかね
まあ一応ボスはいるんですけど
あれは哺乳類ですね そうでないと大体メスですよ
女王になるのは ゾウの場合は群れを司っているのはメスです
オスじゃないんです だから一番頭いいんですけどね
ゾウは他の動物と比べると
はい それから入場券 はい
貪瞋痴に覆われて行動行為をすることです
まあみんな本来貪瞋痴ですからね
もういくらでも無料で入場券はいくらでもあります
はい 罪は10種類ですよ
で これはリストじゃないんですよ
お釈迦様のこの研究の上で10になったんです
貪瞋痴からはどんな行為できるのかというと
これも宗教と関係なく普遍的な罪を見ると10になったんです
それの反対は十善というし
十善十悪 みんな覚えてるでしょうに
殺生すること 盗むこと
よくしめない行為 それから嘘をつくこと
噂を言うこと 悪口を言うこと
それと利息ですね それから
体でメス まあパーリ語で言わなきゃ思い出せません
パーナーてパーディナあれパラミッタアビチャヤでミッターイスト
で それからこの異常な精神的な異常な欲と
精神的な異常な怒りと邪見というのは理性がないこと
だから永遠とかなんとかとか
それはもう邪見ですよ
もうちょこっとした理性で壊せるもん
壊れるもんだからね 危ないんですよ
そんなこと考えると あると
これはパーリ語でダサクサラカマパタというんです
一般日本語 一般日本の仏教を知っている方々も
十善十悪ぐらいはご存知でしょうし
体でやることはメス パーナーティパータアディンナーダーナカーメスメッチャーチャラという殺生と盗むこっち注意中途とジャイン
口で 4つ 嘘 噂 無駄話 悪口
それで 7つ 心で 3つ 精神的にイかれて余計な欲
あるいは精神的にイかれて余計な怒り
あるいは邪見 で 心で 3つ
これは11にもなりませんし 9
にもなりません お釈迦様のリストだから
いくら頑張っても だから人間にこのワードとかリストだよと与える権利あるのは完全真理
発見したブッダのみです
はい 次に行きます その罪の強弱性
回数 罪を正当化すること
罪の意識がないことなどの条件によって
次に生まれるところは自動的に定めます
例えば 人が嘘をついた
地獄3つでしょ？アッパーや3つでしょ
どちらに行くんでしょうかね
畜生に行くか 餓鬼道に行くか
地獄に落ちるか それは強弱性ですよ
嘘の それから回数 回数は少ないんだったらね
もうそんなに大罪にはなりません
それよりひどいのは 罪を正当化するんでしょうがなかったんではないかとかね
あれ しょうがないということはね
嘘を言って これはものすごい危険ですよ
なんか悪いことしてね
あれはもうやっぱりその時しょうがない
あんな条件ではと これを言ってはあかん
罪が重くなるんです 大罪になるんです
罪は悪いんだと たとえ脅迫されてやったにしても
あれは脅迫されてやったんだけど
嫌なこっちゃと 悪いことをしちゃったと
ということで やっぱり思っちゃうともうすぐなくなるんですね
罪の意識がない それも危ないんですよ
罪だと全然思わないでへっちゃらでやる
例えばこの会社では帳簿をごまかすことはみんなずっと何年もやってると罪の意識がなくなるでしょ
大罪になるんですね ずっと政権いろいろごまかしやってきたら
これ五 六年 七 八になってくると当たり前になってくるんです
罪でなくなっちゃうんです
これとっても危ないんです
例えば日本で酒飲むことは罪っていうことにならないでしょうに
文化的にそれはもうなんて言いますか
罪ではないということになっちゃうんですね
だからって罪にならないはずがないんです
残念ですけど そういうことで
畜生に行くか 餓鬼道に行くか
地獄に落ちるかっていうことは
自動的に心の動きですからね
なっちゃいます はい 次に行きます
はい えーと 罪を繰り返さないこと
懺悔すること 犯した罪よりもたくさん善行為をすることなどで
犯した罪が弱 弱になります
弱くなります だから人間はどうせ貪瞋痴だから罪を犯しますよ
それでやらなくちゃいけないことは繰り返さない
一回何か罪を犯したら
では一生やらんぞと こんなものはと
その一生やらんぞと決めたことがすごいんですよ
それであの罪が全部潰れちゃいます
えらい善行為になるんです
あるいは懺悔する あるいはもうちょこちょこちょこちょこちょこちょこ毎日罪を犯してるんだから
もうたくさん善行為をして
もう量的な勝負する それどちらでも仏教では推薦している方法なんです
地獄に落ちたくないならばのことです
いつでも自由があるんです
はい 人生の後期の生き方は
次の生まれを構成するために与える影響は強いんです
これも覚えておいてください
生きていて後期になってくると
その時の思考はかなり影響を与えるんです
もう若い時のこと もうきれいさっぱり忘れているんです
その中からもいい案は出てきます
はい 地獄の楽しみは嫌な人は人生の後期で生き方を改めた方がよさそうです
だから後半ででも生き方を改めればいいんです
後半で改めちゃうと影響は強いんですよ
若い時は話は聞いてくれないし
もう元気でしょうし いろいろ悪いこともやっちゃうし
そこはそういうことはあっても
やっぱり後半になってくるともう気をつけて
後半になってくると 当然怒りやら嫉妬やら憎しみやら
傲慢 強情 もうあらゆる煩悩だけ残るんですよ
若い人々はたまたまいたずらしたり
ちょこちょこいろいろ悪いことするんだけど
結構可愛いんですよ そんなに悪いことしないんですよ
面白いことに ほとんどしないんですよ
もう稀な何人かなんですよ
それも大人に言われて
あるいは仲間に言われて
もう救ってあげると思ったら簡単です
もう 2  3週間  1ヶ月間ぐらい
すごい丁寧に可愛がって大事にしてあげると
ケロッと心が変わるんですよ
若い時は 時々子供なんか見ているんですけども
悪いことをやっているのに
それでもいや やめよう
それ悪いでしょとか そこまで言うんですよ
やめようと言いながらやっているんですから
まあそこら辺でそれほどもう問題はないと思いますよ
大人は違いますからね
だから仏教というのは
この人生の後半ででも改めてくださいと
後半で改めたら覚えてますから
この次の生まれがうまくいくんです
はい それから一つ一つアパーエの説明に入ります
まず この畜生人間に近い
これわかりますか？そこから始まります
はい まあ畜生というのは人間より苦しい
苦しい生まれです 動物の世界は人間よりはすごい苦しい世界なんです
はい 常に殺される怯えがある
これっていうのは大変ですよ
人間は殺される怯えがないでしょ
どれぐらい怖いかと知りたければ
戦争とかあるところに行ってたらどうでしょうかね
イラクでも旅行したらどうですかね
殺される 誘拐されるという
この怖さっていうのは我々は全然感じませんよ
だから人間っていうのは結構落ち着いています
当然殺される人間もいるんだけど
まあ殺されるかも 殺されるかもと誰も思ってないんです
でも動物はそうじゃないんですよ
常にそこがあるんですよ
それだけで地獄なんですよ
この大量に来て 小さなスズメとかいるでしょ
餌でもまいてください
楽しいと思いますかね
餌を食べながら あっち向いてこっち向いたりとかね
あのまく あの種を 1個に 1個食べたところで
もう周りを見て殺されるかないか
ああ  OK やと またということ
大変です 魚はどうですかね
誰も殺されないということはなしと
もう鯨はでっかくても
もう でも鯨も殺すでしょ
はい 自分だけに限った狭い範囲で生きていられる
生きている動物っていうのは
この自分の範囲しか知らない
アリなんかアリの世界しか知らない
人間いることも知りませんよ
人間の体に乗ってるんだから知ってる
知らない 人間がと 目がある動物は他の動物は見られるかもしれませんだけど
これ見るだけ その世界は知らない
だからえらい狭い だから人間で考えてください
我々は永久的に小さなどこかに囲まって
外を出られないように生活しているんだったったら
どれぐらい狭いかと はい
次に行きます しかし 寿命は短いなの短いので苦しみが早く終わるんですね
動物の場合は 大体寿命が短いんですよ
だからカメは何年？鶴千年
カメは万年  カメは万年
鶴は千年  千年とかね 人間もありがたく
いろいろ もうカメはこう
まあ寿命長いんですけどね
結局は地獄の苦しみが長いだけなんですね
鶴はどうか分かりませんだけど
カメは結構長いんですね
生かしておけば でもあの甲羅の中でね
一生生活しなきゃいけないんですよ
歩いているとちょこっと転がっちゃって
裏返し繰り返してしまうとね
亀っていうのはね 楽しいでしょうね
また元に戻れるんだから
戻れる 首足長いは戻れますけどね
ゾウガメは無理でしょうね
それだけで危険です はい
それでも人間などの次元に転生できるかは問題です
無知が中心的な煩悩ですよ
では 犬でも猫でももうもうもう動物はもう早くね
5年  6年  10年  15年で死んじゃいますから
それからまあよかったよかった
人間に生まれたって これはわからないんですよ
人間っていうのは恐ろしい生き方をしているんだから
自分たちでも食い お互いにもうもうもう何て言いますか
これ殺し合いというかね
食い争いというかね 互いに食い合ってますよ
だから反省しないんですよ
人間に頭があるんだから
この地球の恵みでいくらでも生きてられますよ
海の上でもフローティング島を作ってね
生活できます 場所がなければ
それぐらい何のことないでしょうね
でも原子爆弾ばっかり作ったりね
もうもうもう 100億円かかったりして
もうもうもう戦闘飛行機作ったりしてね
なんで海で 海は植えてはもう埋め尽くしてはいけませんだから
フローティング島 フローティングって何でしょうか？英語で浮く
うん そういうふうに島とか作っちゃえば
浮島とか  関西空港  それは沖じゃないでしょうね
上で海作でしょうね で
だから海をそうやって土で埋めちゃうと
また環境破壊にもなりますからね
まあそれはやめてもいいんだけど
でも浮島ぐらい作ったって何のことないでしょうに
住む場所がなければ そちらで米作れますよ
海水は真水にする もう技術は発達すれば
だから人間は正しく 平和のために自分の知識を使うならば
いくら増えても増えても
さらに人間は幸福になるだけ
で これでわからない 貪瞋痴だから互いにもう食い争って
もうお互いに食ってるんです
殺し合いやってるんです
金金ばっかり考えて だから人間もうもう排除してますよ
生まれてくるなよと 邪魔やと
これは仏教から見れば
根本的な話ですよ 生まれてくるなよ
邪魔よと言いながら もう自分たちも死んだら
まあどこか行くでしょうね
だからこの動物が人間に入りたくても
もうこちら全部門限閉めてます
入れません だから生命っていうのは
海の水一滴一滴あるように
もう稼いられないでしょ
無限でしょ 生命は無限にいるんですよ
しかし 徳を積める境地っていうのは
人間の世界なんです 三次元の世間
そちらに入れないんですよ
大変です だから神々は嘘をついているわけじゃないんですよ
神々には特権がありますから
人間の世界はもう調べられますからね
だからもう妊娠できる場所があったら
そちらに入り込むことはできますよ
そこは最悪の家庭だったら徳を積めるところじゃないんですけどね
だから動物が寿命は短いんだから
苦しみが早く終わりますけど
次にどこに生まれるんでしょうかね
それは一番大きい問題で
無知ですから もう何も考えることできないでしょうね
だからそこら辺でもうまたもう生まれちゃいますよ
生まれることは必ず生まれます
もう心はストップしないんだからね
はい 次 餓鬼道について
体はあるが それは暗い心によって構成されたものです
我々みたいなこの餓鬼には
この DNA でアミノ酸でできている体ではありません
心が作った体なんです
化身ですね それが暗い心が作った体なんですよ
だから画家たちが仏画を描く人々は
ああいう風なものすごい
絵を描くんですよ はい
寿命は定められていない
心の暗い回転がある限り続くんです
100年  200年じゃないんですよ
ものすごい長い 餓鬼道が
理由はこの暗い思考で生まれるんですよ
嫉妬 憎しみとかね 我々何か妄想しちゃうと
同じ妄想はもう 10年でも 20年もやってるでしょうに
人間の世界の場合は 考え方が変わることはいくらでもできるでしょうに
部屋の中でやばく暗くなっちゃうと
外に出ればすぐ変わるでしょうに
自分が変わるでしょうに
公園にでも行っちゃえば
なのに我々はワンパターンでずっと妄想してるでしょ
人間さえもこの天界に生まれているのに
神々も羨ましがる場所にいるのに
我々もそんなもんで 餓鬼道の場合はそういう外から情報はないんです
自分の心で 暗い心で体を作っちゃって
その体に適して情報を入れているんです
だから同じ妄想が繰り返すんだから
寿命は長い 一応定めた寿命はないんです
梵天みたいに定めた天界みたいに定めた寿命はないんです
長いことは長い もう 100年
200年じゃないんです
はい 次 自分の心の波動
犯した罪によって体の形と苦しみが変わります
だから餓鬼道っていうのは
動物の世界より幅が大きい
自分の心によってできた体だから
もう似てないんですよ
餓鬼2人は似てないんです
で 苦しみも変わるんです
はい 経典によく出てくる話ですよ
餓鬼道の話は いろんな餓鬼について
もう体の形とかね いろいろ説明はあります
はい 次に行きます 苦楽を分けて受け
それからこの経典の話
まだこっちは出てきてないみたい
あのペータワットという勝負経典テキスト一つあります
そこを注釈と一緒に読むと
ものすごいいろんな餓鬼のことを書いています
それも一部の餓鬼たちなんです
それからサンユットニカーヤにも
ラッカナサンユッタというところがありまして
そこはほとんど餓鬼の話
お釈迦様が見たものやら
ラッカナなんとか長老が見た餓鬼たりやらとかね
そこら辺にもたくさんうろうろしている
いるみたいです はい それである餓鬼は苦も楽も分けて受けるんですよ
ある時期は天皇ごとく幸福にいて
ある時期はある時期餓鬼道の苦しみを受ける
これが回転する このさ
また苦しいですよ ある時期
例えば 1ヶ月間とか 1週間とか 2週間とか
もう神ですよ ものすごい幸せで
そこは日にち終わった途端
餓鬼になるんです ものすごい極端な苦しみを味わわなくちゃいけない
だから極端な楽を味わって
次に極端な苦しみっていうのはね
結構大変ですよ 例えば王様でいて
1 日 次の日はホームレスにしてしまうと １円もない乞食しなくちゃいかないと
もうやりきれんでしょ
できんでしょうね 王様で贅沢に食べていて
次の人から あるいはゴミ箱から拾って食べられないでしょうに
そういう餓鬼もいる はい
ヴィマーナペータという名前ですね
はい 次 ペータワットという勝負経典のテキストに餓鬼道について語っています
そこは知りたければ日本訳もございますので
読んでみてください あんまり大量で講演ではもう言えない
はい 次に行きます 嫉妬
憎しみ 恨み 物惜しみなどの感情が強く罪を犯した生命です
大体餓鬼道に行くのは殺生とかよりも嫉妬
憎しみ 恨みなんですね
物惜しみとかね はい 一部人間の周りに人間に依存しているのです
だから嫉妬 憎しみだから
人間にいた時はかつてね
人間に大切な嫉妬 憎しみ
恨みでしょ 物惜しみでしょ
だから人間から離れないんですね
一部ですよ で うろうろ人間いるところにいる
でも次元違うんだから
別に場所を我々の場所は取れませんし
いくらでもいられます
で 影響はないが 人間のことを嫉妬したり恨んだりでしたっけ
して 自分の苦しみを伸ばして長生きしているんです
で 我々のことをすごい恨んだりするんですよ
嫉妬するんです 例えば
ご飯食べられない餓鬼が
人間がパクパクご飯を食べると
もう我慢できなくなるんですよ
そうすると自分が燃えるんですよ
暗い思考でさらに寿命が延びるんです
だから自分の国では いつでもご飯
我々はご飯食べる前にはちょこっと一つ置いておくんですよ
外に 一番先に 習慣的に
もう子供たちでも 例えばもう遊んでいて
野生のヤブで遊んでマンゴーでも拾ったら
もうそのまま食べないで一部ちょこっと捨てるんです
誰にだろう 餓鬼のためやと
そこら辺にいるんだからと
そうすると自分たちのは同窓ということをしたら
そちらの嫉妬がなくなるんです
そこでいくらかでも幸せになってほしい
だから食べるわけじゃないんですけどね
心ではちょこっと気分がいいんですよ
明るくなるんです まあ餓鬼の影響で
あるいは何て言いますか
幽霊のお化けの影響で恨まれていろいろ不幸になるんだぞという話も日本ではよくありますけど
まあ餓鬼の影響を受けるぐらい人間だらしないということですよ
結局はもう人間だしからもう
もう仲間でしょうね 生きて人間でいたっても
僕なんかは結構知ってます
そこら辺にいる餓鬼たちは全然影響なんともない
時々人間見るとね まあこのちょこっと言うんですよ
あんた方はね これこれちょっとやったらどうでしょうかとかね
まあ私はこのあれなんとか話しませんだから
神秘的な超能力的な話しませんだから論理的にね
これこれこれ良くないんだよとね
このものはこちら置いといかんとかね
それあんまり聞いてくれない
それは私 時々のちょっと影響受けてるんだからね
暗い影響ね それはなんとか破れっていうことでね
で そこを影響を受けるぐらいね
餓鬼たちに 戦争にね これ情けないんですよ
とにかく影響は入らないはずなんです
はい 次に行きます 人間が落ちやすい次元でもあります
餓鬼道っていうのは だって人間なら極悪人っていうのは少ないでしょ
しかし 嫉妬やら憎しみやらもういくらでもあるんだから
物惜しみやらもったいない
もったいないって言いながら
一度も使わないものをずっと置いておいたりして
死ぬ時もそれは捨てられなくてとかね
そういうこと結構ありますから
落ちやすいんですよ そちらは制限してないんだからね
アパーエはいくらでも入ります
はい 餓鬼の苦しみから脱出したいと思っている餓鬼もいるんですよ
もうそれは思えないんですよ
餓鬼たちには 自分の妄想の中で
自分の幻覚の中でいるだけだからね
幻覚の中にいるんですよ
しかし 一部いるんですよ
こんな嫌なことは何とかしたいと
自分の力ではどうにもならないので
人間が行う功徳を期待するんです
だから 人間から明るい波動あれば
誰かちょっと波動を出してくれればという気持ちになるんです
自分では破れません 例えば
ろくに泳げない人が溺れているというと
誰かが手ぐらい伸ばしちゃえばもうすぐ上がれるでしょ
自分で泳ぎに行こうとしたってもできない場合もありますよ
だから渦巻きが激しいんですね
暗い苦しい渦巻きが激しいんだけど
渦巻きに巻かれてもう死んでしまう
溺れる そうとは本人が知っていて
溺れたくないんだと という感じで
そこをそういう餓鬼もいますよ
この餓鬼道からとにかく逃げたいんだけど
自分にはこの暗い波動は出せませんと
で 人間に期待するんです
はい 次 パラダットゥーパジーリという名前なの
その餓鬼たちの名前は
別にその餓鬼たちはその名前知りませんよ
これ お釈迦様がそういう名前をつけてるだけ
象に象と言ったっても
それは象は知りませんだからね
人間は言語使いますから
単語を入れるだけ 他人に与えられたもので生きるという意味なんです
はい この餓鬼たちは親族に期待するんですよ
赤の他人がやってくるということはありえないんだからね
親族に期待するんですね
助けてくれるかなとかね
輪廻の親戚 親族かこの世の親戚かですね
親戚が2種類あります
輪廻の中の親族 かつてのお母さんとかね
過去生の 今も人間でいるとかね
あるいは今自分のもう親族ですね
どちらかに期待するんです
はい まあ日本は大体仏教である
このなんとかいろいろね
こう供養儀式とかね その死んだ人のためにやってるでしょ
それはパラダットジーヴィーところに落ちたならばの話なんです
それから地獄って何なのかと
はい 一番惨めな苦しみだけがある生まれです
これはもう極端に食うだけ
餓鬼道と違うんです はい
自由な行動は何一つもできない
全くもない 餓鬼とまた違う
ものすごい厳しい はい
まあたとえで言えば 刑務所の独房の囚人になったようなもんですよ
刑務所だけじゃなくて
そこもまた独房でという
全くも自由は何もないというすごい厳しいところです
はい はい 次 自由意識がないので
一旦落ちたら幸福な なところへ生まれ変わるのは極端に難しい
自由意識まで取られちゃいますよ
機能しない 極端な食うだけ
だから明るい心を作って地獄からもう立ち上がろうとしたってもうほとんど難しいんですよ
だから仏教で一般的に言うのは
いくらなんでも地獄だけは落ちないようにしなさいよと
落ちたらもう大変やと
はい 寿命はとてつもなく長いんです
はい 次 これでいくらか休憩いたします
すごい時間になりましたので
はい ではそろそろ始まります
はい